I think if you're going to change the
world have to redesign some of
fundamental elements of how the world
works I'm interested in development if
you're going to change development then
we have to really look at the
instruments of development that have to
be changed if you look at how the World
Bank is structured a lot of good people
there but the structure the head of the
World Bank is a political appointee and
it's not a person typically that has
risen through the word bank banks so I
think we need to sort of create
organizations that build up the people
the best people to be in charge and
leave some part of development that is
not necessarily politically connected
and pragmatic enough to recognize there
is a connection there but there's also a
connection for merit-based work that the
development agency can do without
regards to the poor latest political
agenda think about how doja bank would
be if the CEO of deutsche bank was
appointed by the german garment